D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
SPEAK OF THE WAY THAT WE SEE
THIS IS THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE WELL-POSITIONED TO FACE
THESE CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC HISTORIC GAINS THAT WE
HAVE MADE UNDER THIS PRESIDENT,
UNDER THE PRESIDENT IN THE LAST
16 MONTHS.
>> Jesse: THE WHITE HOUSE
SPINNING LIKE THERE IS NO
TOMORROW ON THE ECONOMY AND
CLAIMING IT IS A HISTORIC
SUCCESS, THE ECONOMY IS HISTORIC
UNDER JOE BIDEN FOR ALL THE
WRONG REASONS, THE STOCK MARKET
PLUNGING AND REQUIREMENT
ACCOUNTS.
AFTER JOE SAID HE WANTED TO END
FOSSIL FUELS.
AND INFLATION COSTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THOUSANDS OF
MORE DOLLARS PER YEAR.
NOT STOPPING JOE BIDEN FROM
HITTING THE ROAD TO BASH
REPUBLICANS IN BOASTS ABOUT HIS
SO-CALLED SUCCESSES.
>> 20 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS IN THE LAST GUY.
ENDS PACKED SO MANY AMERICANS
LOST THEIR JOB THAT MY
PREDECESSOR WAS THE SECOND
PRESIDENT IN HISTORY TO LEAVE
OFF WITH FEWER JOBS IN AMERICAN
THEN WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE.
REMEMBER THOSE LONG LINES OF
CARS STRETCHING BACK WAITING FOR
A BOX OF FOOD TO BE PUT IN YOUR
TRUNK?
IT WAS NOT JUST POOR FOLK, IT
WAS WORKING-CLASS AND
MIDDLE-CLASS FOLKS.
A LOT OF PRETTY NICE CARS AND
THOSE LINES.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANYMORE THE
IS LIES ABOUT RECKLESS SPENDING.
OR CHANGING PEOPLE'S LIVES!
THE PROBLEM IS REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO STOP MY PLAN TO
BRING DOWN THE COST ON ORDINARY
FAMILIES.
I BELIEVE IN BIPARTISANSHIP, BUT
I HAVE NO ILLUSIONS ABOUT THIS
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THOUGH MAGA
PARTY THAT THINKS THE AMERICAN
PROBLEM IS THAT AMERICAN
FAMILIES ARE NOT PAYING ENOUGH.
>> Jesse: I DID NOT HEAR A LOT
OF CLAPPING.
>> Dana: THAT WAS EDITED OUT.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: I WAS LISTENING
THINKING I WOULD RIP UP THE
WHOLE PLAN, COMMUNICATIONS PLAN,
RIP IT UP, NOT A COMMUNICATIONS
PROBLEM, THEY HAVE A POLICY
PROBLEM, BUT THEY WILL NOT ADMIT
IT.
AND IT IS THE STRONGEST THING
I'VE EVER SEEN.
THEY CAREEN BETWEEN EVERYTHING
IS GREAT OR WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT AND YOU HAVE ALL OF
THIS THROWING END OF THE TOWEL
BY THE CABINET, I'VE GOT NOTHING
FOR YOU ON THAT, NO, NOT HERE
EITHER.
IT'S A COLLECTIVE THROWING IN OF
THE TOWEL THAT IS JUST A SLAP IN
THE FACE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND I TRY TO FIND A SILVER
LINING AND A HOPEFUL SPOT.
THEY ARE JUST NOT GIVING YOU
ONE.
IT'S AS IF THEY THINK IF WE JUST
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT,
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO CHANGE.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY AGAINST TYPES.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THEY RIP
EVERYTHING UP, TAKE A STEP BACK
AND THINK FOR A SECOND ABOUT
WHAT THEY ARE SAYING, WHAT THEY
ARE DOING, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT
IS JUST LIKE POUNDING A SQUARE
PEG INTO A ROUND HOLE AND IT
DOES NOT FIT.
IT WILL NOT CHANGE ANYTHING, AND
I FEEL BAD FOR PEOPLE.
I FEEL BAD FOR THEM, BECAUSE IT
IS REAL.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE GAS STATION
ANYTHING, WELL, IF I PUT
2 GALLONS AND I CAN AFFORD TO
GET TO WORK TODAY, BUT THIS
KEEPS GOING AND PEOPLE ARE --
I KNOW A GUY IN TENNESSEE, I
READ ABOUT HIM, DID AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE PAPER, HE QUIT HIS JOB
BECAUSE IT COST HIM MORE TO FUEL
UP TO GO TO WORK THEN HE MADE IN
A DAY.
AND IT IS REALLY SAD AND I FEEL
LIKE HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
MR. AMP AT AND IT IS NOT COMING
THROUGH.
>> THE CENTRAL ARGUMENT,
EVERYTHING IS GREAT, IT'S ALL
PUTIN'S FAULT AND I CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT MAKES NO
LOGICAL SENSE.
>> EVERYTHING HE SAID THERE WAS
YOU COULD BUY IF YOU HAD NO
MEMORY OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WHICH WAS COVID WHERE THERE WAS
AN UP EVIL AND PEOPLE WERE
WAITING IN LINE.
THE FACT THAT HE MAKES IT ABOUT
TRUMP IS PRETTY AMAZING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT VIDEO
THERE'S ONLY ONE CONCLUSION IS
THAT HE IS NOT TO RIGHTS, HE IS
NOT WELL.
HE WOULD BE A TERRIFIC PRESIDENT
IF THINGS WERE FINE AND YOU HAD
ALL THE BASICS COVERED, BUT THIS
IS NOT TO THAT TIME.
THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
A CRISIS.
IF YOU HAVE A STRONG ECONOMY AND
YOU HAVE PEACE AND PROSPERITY,
YOU CAN HAVE A BACKSLAPPING BOOB
LIKE HIM.
BUT THIS IS SCARY AT THE FACT
THAT HE NEEDS TO YELL LOUDER AND
LOUDER AS IF THAT IS A POINT,
AND I THINK THAT COMES TO --
I DON'T THINK HE IS CAPABLE OF
THINKING THROUGH THESE THINGS
ANYMORE.
I THINK THAT IT IS YOU CAN
PREDICT THE DISASTER.
WHO IS PROBLEM, REPUBLICANS, AND
ONE HALF OF THE EQUATION IS NOT
THERE.
IT'S BASICALLY A ZERO.
WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU MULTIPLY
SOMETHING BY ZERO?
>> Jesse: HOLD ON, I KNOW
THIS.
>> Greg: YOU GET A ZERO.
HE ONLY CARES ABOUT HIMSELF NOW.
IF IT DOES NOT AFFECT HIM AS A
POLITICIAN OR LEADER OR PERSON
AT HOME, IT DOES NOT MATTER AND
DOES NOT EXIST.
IT'S KIND OF FRIGHTENING IN A
WAY.
>> Jesse: HE HAS TOTALLY LOST.
HE SAID A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WERE FLAT-OUT FALSE, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING ABOUT IT IN
ANY OF THE FALSEHOODS?
>> Geraldo: THERE ARE INDEED
SOME THINGS THAT STRAIN FOR
JEWEL LADY, BUT I FIND IT IRONIC
THAT GRADE FOR INSTANCE PREFERS
TRUMP TO BIDEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE LIGHT OF
THE IS JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS AND
YOU SEE HOW ABSOLUTELY CRAZY HE
BECAME AFTER THE ELECTION AND
HOW CLOSE HE CAME TO IMPEDING
AND DESTROYING THE TRANSITION,
PEACEFUL TRANSITION OF POWER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
BIDEN IS AN OLD FELLOW WHO HAS
SOME FRAGILITY AND
COMMUNICATIONS PROBLEMS AND I'M
MAY BE IF HE IS NOT AS SHARP AS
HE ALWAYS WAS, BUT IF THE
ALTERNATIVE IS HIS PREDECESSOR,
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE, AND
REMEMBER, I LOVE TO
DONALD TRUMP, PLEASE, PLEASE, I
FELT VERY CLOSE TO HIM, KNOWN IN
40 YEARS, 40 YEARS --
>> Greg: AND THEN YOU TURN THE
KNIFE.
>> Geraldo: HE TURNED THE
KNIFE IN AMERICA'S BACK.
IT WAS HIM THAT TURNED THE
KNIFE.
AND IT IS BECOMING CLEAR NOW
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE IN A KIND
OF DENIAL.
IT IS NOT SHOCKING HOW MANY
PEOPLE SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP,
WHAT IS SHOCKING IS HOW MANY
PEOPLE SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP WHO
ALSO BELIEVE THAT HE DID
EVERYTHING HE IS ACCUSED OF
DOING.
>> Greg: WHAT DO THEY CALL
JANUARY 6?
ONE DAY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
ADMINISTRATION.
TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT FOR FOUR
YEARS AND HAD A GREAT ECONOMY,
HEADPIECE.
OH, MY GOD, HIS PERSONALITY
UPSETS YOU, THE MAN HE LOVED SO
MUCH, GERALDO AND NOW IT PAINS
YOU.
THAT WAS ONE DAY.
YOU CAN'T COMPARE THE TWO.
AND AS FAR AS I KNOW, WHAT ARE
THE CONCLUSIONS?
YOU ARE BASING THIS ON AN
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE.
ARE THEY SAYING HE DID ANYTHING
WRONG?
I DID NOT EXPECT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
>> Geraldo: HE INCITED, HE WAS
ABSOLUTELY THE DRIVING FORCE FOR
WHAT WAS THE MOST TRAUMATIC --
>> Greg: IN YOUR OPINION.
>> Geraldo: HOW CAN YOU TALK,
I GET SICK TO MY STOMACH WHEN I
SEE THIS.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS NOT THE
MOST TRAUMATIC EVENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> Geraldo: YOU CUT ME OFF, I
WAS GOING TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT SORRY FOR
CUTTING YOU OFF, LET'S GO TO
JUDGE JEANINE.
IT'S BEEN ON LET'S STAY TO THE
TOPIC IS A DELUSIONAL GUY WHO IS
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC HISTORIC LIST OF THE
COUNTRY.
THIS MAN IS DELUSIONAL.
I'M TELLING YOU HE IS
DELUSIONAL.
YOU CAN'T PRETEND THAT THERE IS
A HISTORIC BOOM WHEN THE TRUTH
IS PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
FOR THEIR GAS AND CAN AFFORD TO
EAT, AND THE BABY FORMULA IN
THIS COUNTRY IS UNDER LOCK AND
KEY.
WE ARE LOOKING LIKE A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY WHEN YOU SEE THE
SHELVES IN THE GROCERY STORES,
AND IT IS JUST STARTING THIS
FOOD SHORTAGE, IT IS COMING,
FOLKS.
IT IS GOING TO GET WORSE BECAUSE
OF FUEL AND FERTILIZER.
IN THE USA, WE HAVE THE FASTEST
GROWING ECONOMY, LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING, THAT IS A LIE.
I LOOKED UP COUNTRIES WITH
FASTER GROWING ECONOMIES IN THE
UNITED STATES AND I AM TAKING MY
TIME, BECAUSE YOU TALKED ABOUT
TRUMP.
LET ME TELL YOU WHO IS DOING
BETTER THAN US, IRELAND IS DOING
BETTER THAN US, CHILE, TURKEY,
COLUMBIA.
DRUG DEALING COLUMBIA.
INDIA, GREECE, CHINA OF COURSE
IS DOING BETTER.
THE UNITED KINGDOM, FRANCE,
ITALY, PANAMA, THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, AND I COULD
GO ON.
AND TO THESE FOOLS ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE HISTORIC ECONOMIC BOOM
THAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY?
THEY ARE LYING TO YOU.
AND LET ME MAKE IT EVEN CLEARER,
EVERY MONTH YOU ARE PAYING A TAX
IN THE AMOUNT OF $400 TO THIS
INFLATION, AND BECAUSE OF THESE
INSISTENCE ON GREEN ENERGY,
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN INSIST ON
SHUTTING DOWN FOSSIL FUELS AND
MAKING US INDEPENDENT, NOW HE IS
ON HIS KNEES TO GO BEG FOR OIL,
AND THE COST OF DIESEL IS SO
MUCH IT IS ACTUALLY CURTAILING
HEAVY EQUIPMENT ROOFS, REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF HOURS THAT FARM
TRACTORS CAN WORK PERMIT SO HOW
ABOUT THAT BUILD BACK BETTER,
FOLKS?
WHEN THE BULLDOZERS AND THE
TRACTORS CAN'T RUN ANYMORE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ENGAGING IN ECONOMIC EUTHANASIA.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE SUFFERING
FROM IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE KILLING AMERICANS EVERY
MONTH WITH THEIR ECONOMIC
POLICIES.
>> Jesse: AND WE ARE LOSING TO
PANAMA YOU SAID?
WE NEED TO STEP IT U